some things are lost in time like tears  in the rain but it looks like Blade  Runner 2 is not one of those things the  sequel to ridley scott sci fi classic  blade runner will hit the silver screen  MLK weekend in 2018 we've heard plenty  of rumors about the sequel over the last  couple of years but it looks like we  finally have a date Harrison Ford will  reprise his role as Deckard and Blade  Runner 2 and you will be joined by Ryan  Gosling Dennis Villanueva the director  of sicario will take the reins and the  script will be written by hampton  fancher the co-writer of the first film  production begins july 2016 in the film  is expected to arrive on january 12 2018  blade runner came out in 1982 and is  based on Phillip K dicks novel do  androids dream of electric sheep we  don't know much about the plot of blade  runner too but according to the wrap the  film takes place decades after the first  for more gaming and entertainment news  stay tuned to gamespot